hello and welcome to this video playing
pirate
52. pirates my intrinsic
did we have a dirty hurry before no
okay i'll go for the troll move
this is 100 provocation there's really
no chess content to h5 here
it's really a different thing compared
to the dirty hairy which is really
which has some points here h5 is
mostly just trolling
so get some kind of open sicilian where
h5 is played
and bishop b5 is played which is
admittedly not making much sense
bishop b5 and h5 i mean they both don't
belong into this position
but that that almost looks like a normal
dirty heavy now
just with the bishop on c4 instead of b5
and that could be interesting i'm trying
to take bishop c5 knight g4
starting those attacks on h2 and f2
and the bishop is really wrong on b5
here so
he's stopping part of this but i can
take
play bishop c5
in some cases knight g4 is possible even
here
based on the fact that knight g4 takes
takes
threatened mate g3 i can sometimes take
so if
for example queen d1 then knight g4 is
uh
maybe possible okay um
i can play a6b5 for very rapid
development knight g4
here can be taken and then
pawn g3 i have queen e5 though
for queen h5
okay how ridiculous is knight g4 knight
g4
takes takes
g3 and then queen e5 for queen h5
i don't see how he stops it and
it sounds odd but i don't see how he
stops it
knight g4 h takes h takes g3 queen e5
for queen h5 how does he stop queen h5
h1 checkmate
rook d1
okay if it doesn't work and i'm a
complete clown then
so be it
queen e5 yeah for queen h5
what am i overlooking it's probably
something very simple i'm
maybe he moves the rook away and after
queen h5
king f1 but i couldn't quite believe
that this is on
okay so queen h5 or
queen h5 king f1
check king e2 this is safe
um
he's got bishop f4 sometimes
yeah what can i say that that sacrifice
just doesn't work
that is the only defense but it is it is
a defense
bishop e3 now
[Music]
we never three check king d2 and white
is
winning
yeah that was that was pretty ridiculous
actually
yeah given that i mean i just have this
which is clearly
fine for me but i i just didn't see why
uh it wouldn't work
and it doesn't work i mean for exactly
the the line that
that he played this is of course
um completely okay and must be i mean
i'm just
time up on a bishop c4 variation
yeah this is um perfectly fine
but okay so let's check this just be
this is the only real defense but it is
enough
yeah rook t1
yeah it just doesn't work it says you
can
um summarize the game into this one
sentence this move does not work
yeah so i should go a6
and then i get something that is very
similar to
in the in the proper open
variation the dirty harry there is
this line
something something like that and a6
you can see i get this basically with
tempo in my
in the game this is a better version of
that line
just don't play knight g4 but i mean
that is a thing
sometimes you um think a move
works and you don't see why it wouldn't
work and then you don't quite believe it
and you don't play it and ultimately it
did work
and here i spotted this just too late
if you really feel something
is playable and working and should be
okay
and you have to trust um yourself in
this case
i was just wrong about it thanks for
watching